This trial and
error approach became
the scientific method, the
basis of all modern medicine.
Observe, experiment,
formulate a hypothesis,
and then test it again
and again until it's
proven false or true.
It's a method passed
down to us by the most
famous graduate of the
Asklepion, Galen of Pergamon.
HOST: Roughly 200 years
after the birth of Christ,
Galen helped lay the
origins of modern medicine.
Galen was a fight doctor who
actually managed to write down
his best practices.
And writing down what
he knew to be true,
he created a corpus
that was not just useful
but was in fact
revered for centuries.
[roar]
[crowd cheering]
[grunting]
[groaning]
[cheering]
[tiger roar]
HOST: With each procedure,
Galen was diving
into undiscovered territory.
Lucky for us, he
kept detailed notes
and recorded all his
successes and his failures.